good afternoon Berlin let's get stuck
into things a bat and ball cost $1 10
the bat cost one dollar more than the
ball how much does the ball cost have a
little think ready who got this answer
hands up please great you got one of two
possible answers what you though got was
the cognitive miser answer the one that
uses shortcuts in the brain this
actually isn't the real answer the real
answer is 5 cents if you look in the
graphic on on that side it really does
it does add up to kind of 5 cents so
that's one example of us thinking that
we're rational but actually acting
irrationally the reason behind the
cognitive miser is that your brain is
actually trying to save mental energy
the brain is a made an amazing thing and
we actually make on average thirty five
thousand decisions in a day but that
mental energy is a finite resource and
we suffer over the day something called
decision fatigue so by the end of it
it's almost as if we're drunk when we're
making decisions but that's just the tip
of the iceberg really why are we all
here today and why am i speaking up here
well biases are really really important
to us because we're all here to create
apps and experiences that really offer
can have long-term relationships with
the customers we're all aiming for high
engagement and a high perceived value
from customers for our products but we
can use biases in positive in a positive
way and a guiding light in the
simplification process to guide them
through the journey of our app in a
really nice and simple way
two scenarios which would you prefer the
number involved above its number of
monthly active users in your app I think
we'd all agree that we'd rather three
million rather than 800,000 let's add
one data point to that engagements
Snorri one now has low engagement the
scenario twos got high and by engagement
I'm defining that as the percentage of
people completing your core action a
core action for example would be
completely posting a tweet on Twitter
pending up putting likes on a board on
Pinterest so actually in this which
which of the two would you rather I'd
highly and strongly suggest that we
actually focus on the 800,000 and the
high engagement the three million is
really just a vanity metric
let's go six months into the future and
now we've seen how focusing on high
engagement and that's leading to high
retention you've been able to build up
the monthly active users to five million
and so that's with using these little
nudges there's little biases these
guiding lights to help your customers
along the journeys within the apps that
you've built having been in this
business for a long time there's a few
questions we ask ourselves when we're
designing and building apps simple
questions really is it clear what the
app does in that first five or 10 second
experience for the customer really out
are you getting the value across are you
finding that hook in terms of value as
well generally to create value either
save people time save people money or
enhanced an experience or it's a
combination of the three so think about
how you actually create some value for
the customer and also going back to that
core action try and design that whole
experience of your app around that
specific simple core action and use
those biases to kind of help them along
the way to complete that core action
also along that journey how can you
provide a sense of progress to make them
feel like they're progressing to the end
goal
we live in a very noisy world
we've got push notifications social
messages adverts emails phone calls all
from all sorts of different devices we
live in an age of the distraction with
that in mind it's never been more
important to consider a few things
specifically context and past behavior
when you're thinking about sending
triggers out to your customers even
better you can you can there are now
SDKs available that allow you to look at
the past behavior that the habits are
the lifestyle of your users and predict
when is best to send out those push
notifications as as used by my days
using the the newer SDK it's amazing the
kind of tools that we've got access to
also worth considering other other tools
like the Google awareness API which can
provide a sense of context to your to
your app in terms of what use that what
state the users in are they driving are
they walking
do they have their headphones plugged in
these little nuances how and when you're
pushing out triggers really have a
long-term positive effects on your
retention and engagement the power of
defaults this is often overlooked but
hugely hugely useful to simplifying the
customers experience here we've got a
top-up wheel for a mobile coffee loyalty
app there are seven segments now the the
numbers in green which one of those do
you think we should place in the default
highlighted segments in the will anyway
give me a shout 10:30 okay we got we've
got some smart people here firstly so 30
is correct simply I mean we we chose 30
as default here because it was in the
middle of the range and the end result
of that was the the average top up value
roughly around 20 pounds here where
originally the business thought it was
going to be around 10 pounds now with
all these biases and guiding lights and
nudges it's all it's great to integrate
into an app but it really does have a
positive long-term effect and this was
the case with this Pacific at the 50% of
orders were coming from the app for
certain for certain saws and that
compares to the market leader in the
coffee space having an average of 21% of
orders coming from the app so these
little nudges really help I think a huge
number of us have heard of the classic
jam jar experiment whereby 24 Giants
compared to 6 jams that 3% of the the
people who are shown 24 jams buy a jam
compared to 40% of people who buy for
one of one of the six so that's called
the pallets of choice and this applied
to menu design here I start off with
showing 50 options so you got every
option under Under the Sun on the
starting screen obviously too far too
many you're introducing cognitive load
into the experience you're making use of
work too hard so let's just apply some
some kind of common sense to that list
and we end up with the second screen 10
options there's still a struggle list
but we can do so much more for the
customer the ideal could be just one
user was like we want you one option the
smarts the perfect option the perfect
option that takes into account the
context that's true but it's also worth
considering the last screen on the far
hand side of providing three options why
would you want to write three options to
give a sense of choice to your customer
to allow them to control their journey
through your wrap all these behavioral
biases are really kind of stemming from
the last 60 years of research in
behavioral science
but new concepts and theories are coming
out on a weekly basis there's a problem
though in that they're really largely
very dry very academic maths written
sometimes actually hard to get hold of
and fundamentally also not very
practical in their original form
so we discovered this particular problem
two or three years ago and decides it
secretes a little microsites called coke
load calm which basically is a
collection of all these lovely
behavioral biases pulled together into
one location but redesigns and rewritten
so that it's in a format that's
digestible understandable and also
practical to us who are the designers
and developers of today's products and
the future so poke poke calm and I might
have something to give out later on with
all this speak about biases how best do
you in zero integrate this thinking into
the way that you're designing and
building your apps one of the methods
that we've got is we call it the Cognos
focus methods we have biases on every
whole stack of cards we we put it all
out on the table and collectively when
within the team we look at what's most
applicable to that particular edge that
brands and we make sure that everyone
understands the biases then we go off in
your individual little corners of the
room and brainstorm ideas around how to
integrate that how to best integrate
that bias into the experience for the
benefit of the customer also is worth
keep in mind the values of the client or
the product the strategy that you've got
and also think about the emotion that
you are looking to evoke by someone
using your your tool or app then come
back to sit together present your best
idea to the team but think about that
the actual problem that you're looking
to tackle
present the idea how it aligns with the
brand's present also the assumptions and
risks do you think involved in there and
how you're gonna test and make make that
minimal test and who's going to be
involved in that
the memorize app what one of my most
favorite apps in the world and I just
wanted to take a moment to focus you in
on to the very top of the screen the
green area this is the first time this
screen has been shown to me the user the
first time user but there's two ticks
here this is what's called the endowed
Progress effects and it's a feeling that
you've already made a great start so
you're more likely to progress to that
end goal completing that line developing
a behavior positive behavior and it's
all stems from research originally done
in the US for a car wash who trialed two
different loyalty cards the first of all
tea card had eight stamps the second
loyalty card had ten stamps but two were
prefilled which is the loyalty card that
performed the best it was the one that
had the two prefilled stamps it was
though that was the card that was
completed the most often that was
completed the quickest and had the most
loyal customers another lovely graphic
here the Harvard Business Review
pyramids now two things to take from
this slide try and involve as many of
these points in that pair in this
pyramid as possible in your app and what
you will then create is is customer
loyalty and high engagement one other
thing from this pyramid is emotion again
it's really important to just ask this
simple question when you're designing
and building your app what emotion am I
looking to evoke it might simply be a
smile it might be some stage past
emotion like salivation which which is
an amusing one but it's a very simple
question and it acts as a really lovely
simple guiding lights to make sure that
the value you're creating is is high
enough and beneficial to the customer
now this is an app that I hope you've
all got installed already on your on
your devices playbook for developers
which is a goal
mine of nuggets for anyone building
businesses on top of Google platforms
and I just wanted to showcase two
particular biases that are there
integrated into the app you've got the
sunk cost effect which by which is as
you spend more time investing it within
within a tool or products you're you're
far less likely to leave and so over
over the days or months that you're
using the PlayBook app you're
personalizing it so then you're getting
a more personalized feeds and again less
likely to leave then there's a humor
effect nothing could it's not really
connected to a feature but it's used
here really to create a more lasting
memory which helps with retention so you
know we always want to get dancing
androids into our into our apps as I'm
also mentioned before it's not always
about features think about also the low
moments in the naps experience when the
network fails when something when
there's an internal error within the app
when you when you're in that first
default state where you don't have any
saved items how can you use these design
nudges in a positive way to turn what
actually might feel initially quite
negative soften that and maybe you can
even turn that into a positive
experience and maybe make someone smile
by showing a kind of cute robot the last
case study I wanted to highlight today
was is the mga app which is an app that
sells shoes and the really interesting
bias that they've integrated here is
that of limited availability so you have
this notion of editions that they
release every single week but within
those editions there's a certain number
of shoes so limited availability
actually on the shoes and then there's a
limited window of 12 weeks for each shoe
so the result of all that they ended up
having an industry the highest
converting sales channel on mobile that
was their highest promoted so strong
channel and it was four to five times
the energy standards of conversions of
push
these things really do work and are very
very useful for both customer and client
all this said like I said before you
with biases come power they can be used
for negative negative effect but it's
it's not the time to use that really for
creating long term engagement retention
the customer has to be right at the
heart of heart of it all and you can use
this positive biases in so many ways to
create that positive emotion for the
customer I so this is people always end
on a peak ends rule bias which creates a
longer lasting memory find me at the
break I've got a limited number of
special things to give up give out so
limited availability bias there also
humor bias creates a longer lasting
memory merci danke thank you
you